I'd like to start today with Law and
Order or law and auto depending on your
preference I know that it feels like
just yesterday that the failed former
president Donald Trump went from being a
once indicted president to a twice
indicted former president but we are now
potentially inching up imminently on
Donald Trump's third arrested indictment
and potentially even fourth arrest and
indictment there is a very interesting
report from NBC News five or six Secret
Service agents have testified before the
January 6 grand jury sources say it is
not known what the agent's proximity to
Trump was on January 6th or what
information they may have provided
through the grand jury it's important to
remember that and it's hard to keep
track of I admit if you're busy working
listen I work in doing this and it's
hard to keep track of all of the
investigations and potential arrests
that are forthcoming involving the
failed former president
um if you have like a real job I can
only imagine that it is a mess of
confusion what is going on Donald Trump
has been arrested and indicted at the
state level in New York Donald Trump has
been arrested and indicted federally
related to the classified documents
Fiasco there is a concurrent federal
investigation into Donald Trump's role
related to the January 6th riots so
while that is going on we also have to
remember what's going on in Georgia with
Bonnie Willis so let's go through the
possible forthcoming arrests
I don't really know which one we would
call the third or the fourth what I mean
by that is we don't exactly know which
is likely to happen first or next but
the next federal arrest would be related
to the house committee investigation
into the January 6 Trump riots those
investigations led to criminal referrals
to the justice department federal
charges remember
and they relate to allegations belief
the suggestion that Donald Trump
attempted to incite an Insurrection
participated in a conspiracy to defraud
the United States obstructed official
proceedings conspiracy to make false
statements Etc all of that has been
referred to the justice department for
potential Federal prosecution that's
what this is all about the Secret
Service agents that testified the
um subject matter presumably about which
they were asked and testified all
relates to a concurrent special counsel
investigation by Jack Smith Jack Smith
is the same special prosecutor involved
in Trump's existing Federal indictment
this may be a second Federal indictment
spokeswoman for the secret service has
so far declined to comment the content
of the subpoenas and appearances is not
known
Secret Service agents who were close to
Trump on January 6th may be able to
confirm deny or provide more details on
that story first told by Cassidy
Hutchinson you of course remember her
explosive testimony under oath by the
way under oath we then get to the
potential fourth arrest the fourth
arrest would come out of Fulton County
Georgia this is the arrest the
investigation rather being handled by
the district attorney fonnie Willis and
this relates to Trump's attempt to
overturn the results in Georgia remember
that Joe Biden won Georgia in the sense
that he received more votes than Donald
Trump I know that now and you know for
all of the attacks from the ride about
postmodern leftists were words no longer
have meaning what we mean by Trump lost
and Biden won is that Biden received
more votes in concurrence with the will
of the voters of Georgia it's not super
complicated he won in this sense that he
got more votes than Trump that's where
Trump's famous phone call where he said
I need 11 000 votes give me a break that
entire Fiasco is the subject matter of
the Georgia investigation from which a
fourth arrest could come a special grand
jury heard evidence in that case for
roughly seven months and
um there were a dozen or so indictments
recommended it was hinted at by that
zany and kooky jury 4 person that Trump
may be among those recommended
indictments we will uh see probably uh
during that session of the grand jury
the the grand jury term from July 11th
to September 1st that is the time range
during which we would expect that arrest
so as we continue to see
that nobody else in the 2024 Republican
primary seems to be able to make any
progress Chris Christie as as we said
yesterday tongue-in-cheek Chris
Christie's polling has surged 150
percent from one percent to 2.5 percent
but DeSantis Ron de sanctimonious he's
flat
um Nikki Haley four percent you know
everybody's flat and Trump is
essentially flat as well nobody seems to
be able to make any progress against
Trump despite now two arrests would a
third arrest damage Trump would a fourth
arrest damage Trump increasingly my
guess is that the answer is no we may
find out about that soon let's now talk
about an explosive development remember
Law and Order folks Law and Order you've
got to have law you've got to have order
explosive development in Trump's
existing Federal indictment
sometimes it can be tough to maintain an
emotional connection with your
significant other you might work in
different places at different times
there might be a kid in the way it can
be hard to find time for date nights
especially because kids demand so much
attention which is why I love our
sponsor paired which is the app for
couples the app will prompt you with a
daily question or a game or a guided
conversation all designed by Leading
psychologists and the point is to just
have a deeper connection with your
partner boost intimacy build a deeper
knowledge of one another my girlfriend
and I will use the prompts on paired
throughout the day to stay connected for
instance we answered a prompt about what
we remember most from the early days of
the relationship it really helps us
learn new things and there can be funny
moments as well an independent study
found that couples using paired saw 36
percent increase in the quality of their
relationship and giving a paired
subscription as a gift is also a really
great idea you can try it free for seven
days and get 25 off a subscription go to
pair.com Pacman the link is in the
description